From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
You want this to happen any more?
Sure.
Today is Monday, July 25, 2011.
My name is Joe Manier of the Southern World History Program at the University of North Carolina at Chapelville.
I'm with our project, Video of the Fert John Fisher in Ithaca, New York, to do an oral history interview for the Civil Rights History Project,
which is a joint undertaking of Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture and the Library of Congress.
And we're delighted this morning to be with you, Ms. Cotton, and Ms. Dorothy Cotton.
Thank you, I'm here to hear your Ithaca to spend some time talking about Civil Rights History.
Thank you.
Let me ask a very broad first question for some reflections I have read where you wrote that you wrote the follow and kind of thinking about the world that you came up in.
You wrote from a very early age I felt like I was in the wrong place.
Yes.
It's not interesting.
It is to me that the sense that I was in the wrong place was very, just sort of pervasive in my being.
I couldn't put words on it at the time that I was feeling that as a youngster.
But of course, as the years have moved on and I've moved on, I still reflect on it and have learned to have come clear on just that fact that I was supposed to be somewhere else.
This is not my home community even.
It was alien, alien to something in my very being.
I don't know if you know something about that neighborhood.
917 North Greenlee Street in Goldsboro, North Carolina, where I was born.
And outhouse in the backyard and people fighting and doing horrible things to each other.
And that must have had something to do with it.
Just the behavior of the people, not just the behavior.
I don't know the way they were, the people in that neighborhood felt alien to me even as a child.
And I think you lost your mother.
My mother died when I was three years old.
And of course, that was the depression and segregated southern town.
What can you say to kind of frame the circumstances of your father's life after having lost his wife and the poor children's arrays?
What do I say about my father now?
And in these days, incidentally, my feeling about my father, my understanding of my father has evolved.
When we were children, he was just the big guy.
And he really wasn't big at all, skinny guy actually.
But here's this big man raising full girls.
And I know a lot, and I understand a great deal about him in retrospect.
I know now that he went to, I think he said the third grade.
And that's what stands out for me that he went to the third grade.
Now, no matter did he just get to the third grade, they lived way out somewhere.
I must research that place on somebody's farm, kind of a plantation kind of place.
And his mother worked for a white family.
It's interesting. I sort of choke on that kind of language now.
I really don't even, one day, if I get, if I'm on the planet longer,
if I'm going to create a whole new genre of language with which to describe people,
because I'm really, I've jumped forward here.
But it seems so just silly, ridiculous to me to continue to refer to people based on a color.
As I said to a friend recently, well, she wasn't even a friend.
I was doing a speech and I pointed to a woman sitting down front with a white blouse on.
I said, they call you a white woman.
But you know what, if you were the color of your blouse, I would call the ambulance and get you to a hospital.
And my dress that I was wearing was black.
My skin, Andrew Jung calls it, I was a pecan tan.
And so there's nothing old here.
You know, it's not literal.
But anyway, I sort of digress here.
But I think about my father with a great deal of sadness now.
And but also some anger, I can forgive to some degree the things that I,
well, the part of his behavior that makes me angry and that is still hurtful,
because I'm wise enough now to accept the fact that he didn't know any better.
For example, the way he would discipline us, these four, I'm three.
We were one two, less than one year old, three and four, the four of us, when my mother died.
His notion of how you teach children and punish them was to take a strap and they were not soft blows.
I can still feel anger about that.
But I have very mixed feelings about him because again, that's what was done to him.
And I learned that very late in life that his mother would come home from taking care back to the color thing again.
This white family and their children, his mother would come home late at night having left her children all alone.
When she'd get home and my dad's older sister, Aunt Penny said this to me.
I said, I'm Penny, how are you all punished?
Now, after I'm now reflecting on the ridiculousness and the pain of the way he punish does.
And Penny, his sister said, well, when Mama would get home, she would find a reason to whip all of us with a switch.
Sometimes they had to go get the switch.
And it's even more horrible things than that.
So I have such mixed feelings.
Fast forward to the mixture now as I look back at my dad and as I do things that would be just beyond his imagination.
I was in South Africa and I thought, oh, my dad could have had the experience of traveling to South Africa.
If my dad, I mean, I've been in Chai, I've been in a lot of countries.
If he could, my dad never even had an airplane ride.
And even going to an airport was very special for him.
Because that was not a part of his world.
Even when we were all out of the house and one of my mother's sisters passed by and my dad was sitting on the porch,
and you're by himself and my aunt said, Claude, get in the car and come go with me up to Buffalo, New York.
My dad, sitting on the porch and Goesborough, North Carolina, jumped in my car.
Had no plans to do that.
Got up to Buffalo, New York, and set up his house keeping function there.
So my, the sadness that I feel now is I'll give you a little anecdote and then I'll stop talking about him.
We went, I flew there and to see him at some point.
And after he'd been there a few years.
And my dad, I said, can you want to go to the airport with us on a cousin who was living there.
Drove us to the airport.
And it was only five or six of us.
And my dad, he was working at the Bethlehem Steel mills there.
And when we finished eating in the airport, my dad pulled out his wallet and paid something like $42 for the five or six of us to eat.
You could imagine that was some years ago.
You wouldn't, you wouldn't eat for five or six people for that amount of money.
One dinner would cost that now.
And, and I remember much later, but that was very special for him.
First of all, to be in the airport.
And, and to pay that because my dad would have paid, would have had less than that amount of money for a week's work when we were children in Goldberg, North Carolina.
Working in this tobacco factory.
Back to Goldberg now in the tobacco factory.
His job was to put tops on barrels where he'd have to use a hammer.
And I'm not sure what it's called.
It's a hammer on one side and an axe.
Because he chopped a part of his finger off with that axe one day.
Axe, hammer, I'm not, again, not sure what it's called.
But, so he had that they did let him come home from work.
And he got him to the hospital first and they sort of sold it back on what they did.
But you could tell, he'd been injured.
But back to the, now having made his way to Buffalo, New York.
Being in the airport was very special.
Another time when I had flown there, a cousin who lives there took me to the airport to get my ticket.
And I was there to see him.
When I got back home, he was sullen and quiet back to his house.
And he was hurt because he didn't get to go to the airport.
That was so special for him.
Before I cry, I'm going to stop talking about him.
It's a weird, it's just, it's very painful.
The deprivation and what was so special to him.
But, well, one way to speak of my dad was a real mixture.
My own feeling is first of all, a real mixture of feelings.
First, I can still be angry, feel angry.
I feel the anger about the beatings for the, you break a dish.
You know, he's got his belt off.
But I can also remember, at Christmas time, he had a smile on his face when he could get off over a doll.
And a T-set and our own box of fruit.
And he was a shoe box.
And he was so proud that he was able to do that.
So, you can see, it was such a, oh, there must be a word for this.
Such a mixture, both in terms of my own feelings and my own assessment of him.
And his own feelings about his life and his work.
But right now, in the year 2011, most of my feelings, sort of about my dad,
revolves around the deprivation of his life, his treatment.
My dad was really nervous in front of white folks.
And so, that's, it's a real mixture of my feelings about him.
A kind of love for him.
An understanding of the sort of mixed, that must be word for this as well,
feeling about his life and his relationship to us.
It's positive, just a second.
We'll go back on after a short break.
Ms. Cotton, let me ask you about, I think in your life, as sometimes happens,
as folks come up, there was a teacher, a high school teacher in your place.
Oh, yes.
There was, it would be a very tremendous influence.
And it helped you take a look step forward towards college and probably.
I thought you were going to ask me what made me, there's a little story I want to tell you about,
I think I was around 10 years old, back on Greenleaf Street at North Goalsboro.
When a little white boy was riding his bicycle down my block, kicking up dust,
because the pavement stopped at that, it got through the white section.
And he was singing, you may be familiar with the song, deep in the heart of Texas,
where he was singing, deep in the heart of Nigger Town.
I wanted to tell you that because I have never, ever forgotten that that made me angry.
That little white boy was riding down my street singing that.
Now, want to go back to high school?
Okay, that's what my high school days.
Yes, I wish I could thank her in person, but Ms. Rosa Gray was my English teacher.
Ms. Rosa Gray was not only the English teacher, she was responsible for the annual play for the high school.
And I got the leading role in the high school play every single year.
And I felt such a connection to her.
But even before probably more than being aware and conscious of how special it was,
that she would name me this poor little girl from Greenleaf Street.
But the teachers were poor too, compared to today.
We had to, in the English classes, one day we had been required to memorize some poetry.
And I don't remember what the poem was, but I do remember that as I stood before the class
and recited the poem, and as I headed back to my seat, she said very audibly,
there's your ready girl till this day that phrase, that description just goes around and around in my consciousness.
There's your ready girl.
But I knew that, I think I'm going to cry.
I knew that I never wanted to disappoint her.
I wish there was something, not too much, that is the personal thing necessarily,
but was she something of a surrogate mother since you had lost your mother?
It's interesting that you say that.
I never thought of her as a surrogate mother, but maybe she was a surrogate mother,
because I had no mother.
She would...
This is...
Did you take it on that?
Yeah, let's just take a little break.
Okay, we're back after a short break.
We're talking about Miss Gray.
Of course, my sister would tease me a little bit, and when I talk about my fondness for her and my members of her,
excuse me, relationship with my English teacher, she's...
Are you sure you didn't love Miss Gray?
She was going to make sure you got lunch.
But she was...
We all had a little laugh about that, because I was...
I wasn't feeling...
Anyway, I had...
Just some other feelings...
My sister made me laugh.
But another example...
It's the notion of Miss Gray being a surrogate mother is what really got to me,
because I never thought of it that way, but I think that's true.
She...
There's the junior senior prom in high school, and when it was time to go to the junior senior prom,
my dad was not going to let me go.
Miss Gray came to my house, sat on the porch, and those little houses along there,
those little three little row houses, and they're all torn down now.
But the porch was high, so I wanted to get under the porch.
My dad was sitting on the front porch, and my teacher, Miss Rose Gray,
sat there, offered her a chair, and she was pleading with him to let me go to the junior senior prom.
She said, she would...
Shaperone me?
I don't know if dad knew what the word Shaperone meant, bless his soul.
But I think he said she would take care of me.
But she was pleading with him to let me go.
I mean, I'm her star pupil, and I can't go to the junior senior prom.
And I remember that I, under the house, under the porch listening,
that I was really upset, and fast forward, believe it or not, 30 or 40 years later.
It came clear to me why my dad said I could not go.
I'm sure my dad, as poor as he was, was a very proud man.
He would not let me go to the junior senior prom, and that's what could be as dressed up as any other child.
He had no money for that.
He couldn't tell her that.
He said, he said, I just, he wasn't ready for my girls to go to dances.
That's what he said.
He was going to talk proper for the teacher.
I told you he went to the third grade and living out on that farm.
Did you come up in the church?
Not really.
My dad had a brief marriage to someone who was, I guess they married yet.
It's interesting that I never knew, but she was there as the stepmother, Mrs. and me.
And I don't know what her name was before.
I'm pretty sure they married, but I don't know anything about the ceremony or anything like that.
I don't know how many years, but it didn't last long.
And fast forward to a time when we all grown and married and living our various lives, my three sisters and I.
And my dad, confessing to us that I wasn't loving Susie Mae.
Those are his exact words.
I just brought her in there to help take care of you, young ones.
So that's why we had this stepmother for a while.
And the stepmother back to church was very much a church-going woman.
I remember once she was taking all four of us to church and there was a very threatening storm was pending, thunder and lightning.
And we were walking to the church and all four of us in tow with Mrs. and me.
And we always called them Mrs. and me.
And when she decided she needed to go back to the house because the lightning was so strong and fierce.
And we turned around and went back to the house.
And as she got to the house, she said, that won't, nothing but the devil.
And so she was very much into church.
So she would put this on the devil and to keep her from going to church.
So that was a memory I have of Mrs. Mae.
I don't know when she left or how she left, but it wasn't long.
Fast forward, we reconnected with her like 40 or 50 years later.
And she died.
Now, but we reconnected with her.
But she married.
And she married someone she called in Bishop somebody and was living in Florida.
And I saw her.
Yeah, Mrs. Mae.
She, yeah.
Okay, I got to short break.
Yeah.
I want to tell you, my dad, I never knew my dad to sit foot in the church except when his mother died.
As a matter of fact, I think my dad was anti church because I remember his saying,
we were, I guess, late teenagers.
Then somebody who was calling himself a preacher said, my dad said,
that ain't nothing but his racket.
Maybe true folks, some of the folks who call themselves Reverend as well.
He's a way to make sure you have it income was my dad's thought.
Nothing but a racket.
But when he, I remember his going, of course, when his mother died,
and we were all there, of course.
And I remember his crying in the church bending over with his handkerchief to his face.
But other than that, my dad, but my mother, my actual blood mother,
my, I knew her father.
He was a preacher.
And, and I, a tenorant preacher went from a small town to small town.
And I think he and my dad actually hated each other.
And my dad did confess, I'm not sure in what context, but he used the word
stole.
In other words, they looked, Maggie, my mother's name.
She was quite young.
I'm not sure how old, but quite young when my dad had married her,
but they ran off and got married.
And I think that grandpa, her father, Mr. Reverend Seymour Pellum,
and Reverend Seymour Pellum would come by the house.
We did call him grandpa, but he would, I could just tell that the energy wasn't right
in the house when grandpa stopped by.
Let me take you back to Miss Grandford just a moment.
Oh, yes.
As I understand, she would be, she was the part of the story.
She's in the story regarding your transition to Rolly to a ten shop.
Yes.
Miss Gray, but we used to sing a song.
They used to sing people, church-going people in those days used to sing a song.
I know the Lord laid his hands on me, meaning that as a metaphor, you know,
that she laid her hands on me in a very special way, in other words.
Sort of took control of just really special events, or control of me in a special way.
But Miss Gray knew that college was not in the offing for me,
but she called over to Shaw University when I was about to graduate from high school.
And talked to, I don't know, who, how, one got to go, who you talked to to get to go to college.
But Miss Gray talked to someone there at Shaw, and I ended up being accepted as a student at Shaw University.
She had gotten two jobs for me.
One job was working in the dining hall.
The other job was cleaning the teacher's dormitory on the campus at Shaw University.
Eventually, well, eventually it makes it sound like a long time, but it wasn't very long before I was offered a job to be,
they didn't use the term, but a housekeeper in the president's residence.
For a very short time, I had three jobs working my way through college.
My dad never gave me a dime.
I don't blame him for that. He didn't have any money to, and probably didn't know what college was, not really.
But so I was cleaning the teacher's dormitory, and eventually I was able to give up one of the jobs.
I think that was the one that I gave up, and still worked in the dining hall for a little while.
But when I must have been a good worker and a good cleaner in the teacher's dormitory,
because I was invited to come and be a housekeeper for the president.
Dr. Robert Printis Daniel, and his wife Blanche Daniel, they had me coming over to instead of the teacher's dormitory to help take care of the president's residence.
Dr. and Mrs. Daniel had no children, and I had a sense that ultimately,
in a way I was part daughter and part housekeeper.
I worked very hard in that house, though, and it was a three-story house.
I stayed through graduation and getting married.
I felt like I was part daughter and part housekeeper.
The housekeeping part, or even being with them, the Daniels, the president of Shaw University.
It was not a happy relationship, so I'm taking care of the house.
Sometimes I get a feeling that they wanted me to act like a daughter.
That too was a very complicated relationship, because they weren't really nice to me.
I remember once I had the flu, and Dr. Daniel said, you can't just go to bed because you don't feel well.
He even said that to me.
I got a check for a fast forward job in the library.
That's really quite forehead, but I'm still living there.
Mrs. Daniel opened the envelope. She wanted to see how much I was baking.
I have to tell you a little anecdote about my dad.
My dad came from Goldsboro while I was a student there at Shaw, and I'm now in the president's home.
My dad had never seen the flowers in the president's residence.
He said, what in the world does anybody want that flower shining like this for?
I was the one who polished those flowers and put the wax on the flowers or whatever for a while.
Then they had another fellow Robinson.
This all I remember is Robinson.
It's never knew his first name would come and do some things in the house.
But I became sort of a, I think in a way they loved having me there, having no children of their own.
But at the same time, I don't have happy memories of being there, but it was helpful because they saw that.
I went to class. It took me at least six years to get my college degree.
I was in a class with a fellow, I think his name is Harris Sims, was a classmate of mine.
In a class, Shakespearean class, we both loved Shakespeare.
I remember that poem. I said in her class, I love reciting Shakespearean poetry.
And this fellow, Harris Sims sat next to me in this Shakespearean class studying Shakespeare.
And we used to walk down the hill, Harris Sims and I, to have a beverage.
We didn't have a campus center as they do on campuses now.
But there was a fellow who had a place for students to hang out and have refreshments just down the hill from Virginia State College.
And sitting there one day of Sims said to me, I have a fellow I'd like you to meet.
And his name is George Cotton, fast forward, you can imagine.
So George Cotton, this, quite, must have been, George was at least ten years older than I, but that was not an issue then.
And I remember that they had this great big Buick.
And I had the sense that, anyway, George Cotton took a liken to me.
And I've read somewhere that people say I met George Cotton in college suggesting that he was a student as well.
But he was not. George never went to college. I don't know how far George Cotton went to school, but even.
But Cotton got to be quite heavy fast forward to a time when I actually said, actually I didn't say yes.
He didn't ask me to marry him. He showed up one day with a ring and very correctly wanted to speak to Dr. Daniel.
And I knew at that point what he was going to do. I didn't know he had a ring, but he wanted to ask for my hand.
I wonder what George learned that.
I stood at the top of the stairs holding onto the banister.
And I heard George saying to Dr. Daniel that he wanted to marry me and he wanted their blessing.
And I remember that Dr. Daniel said to George, D'Artha is very ambitious.
You sure you want this marriage.
And George said, yes sir.
George Cotton and I got married in the president's residence, this place where I scrubbed for the worst.
Not scrubbed polished floors, then cooked, served meals.
And again, I was a housekeeper and part daughter I used to say.
But a very mixed, I could say a lot about the mixture of my energy.
One of those questions on that point and maybe this will illustrate that attention.
When Dr. Daniel made the transition from Shaw to Virginia State in 1950, and you moved and shifted your college to the moment up there.
Or you?
Yeah, I'm still at Shaw.
And what I was just saying was that Virginia State College at that point.
When I moved, when Dr. Daniel was offered the president's of Virginia State College,
I guess I was a really good house cleaner because they wanted me to go with them.
Yeah, I was ahead of the story because all of it, what I was just talking about happened at Virginia State College.
I was at Shaw probably no more than one year, one school year.
And went to Virginia State College because Dr. Daniel became president of Virginia State College.
And this is where, and this is where I mentioned the classmate, Sims, and I meant, anyway, I'm sorry.
No, no, I was just curious.
Yeah, but that was interesting because I was thinking about being on the campus, but I need to, which campus am I talking about now?
When Dr. Daniel got the offer?
Of course, it would be in Petersburg where you would be drawn after college more directly into early movement activities.
Well, I got to Virginia State College.
And that Virginia State College, again, that's where this Sims, and I were in the Shakespearean class, that was not as short, was at Virginia State College.
And George Cotton lived there in Pita's bird.
And when I said yes, I would marry him and even had the ring, I think he gave me the ring that later on that evening.
And there was a little wedding right there in the house.
I meant.
That's a policy for Christus.
Do you not have a turn to...
Okay, we're back down.
That's a little break.
For the telephone.
So did we get married here?
We were very...
We were talking about how you would be drawn into...
I want to tell you about a little boy, because I consider this the beginning.
Not so much drawn into the movement, but a particular consciousness was evolving.
And back to my childhood, when...
Did I tell you about the little boy driving down the sidewalks, seeing deep in the heart of Nigger Town?
Okay, I know that a consciousness about the wrongness of this system was that opened it up for me.
Okay, fast-forward to Virginia State College.
And when I became active in a church in...
Pita's bird, Virginia.
I got to sit his right here.
And the Reverend Wyatt T. Walker was pastor of this church.
And I'm not sure why I started going there, except that Wyatt T. Walker was also the regional head of the NAACP.
And also the other...
I think it seems like all of the organizations really related were very close to Congress or racial equality and at the time.
And I think I was drawn to that church because of his...
He was also a really good preacher.
And he also was a very handsome guy.
We used to tease each other because my house became the house after getting really involved with all of his extracurricular activities and also very active in the church.
Even on programs sometimes still doing poetry.
I remember reading poetry from the balcony in the church.
And it was just really fun hanging out with Reverend Walker.
So being active, he's running the NAACP and becoming concerned that Black folk could not use the public library.
He took a real initiative there around that library discrimination in the library.
And I thought, just imagine we can't use the public library and yet they, white folks, call us ignorant.
And I felt that very strongly now as...
I'm not sure exactly what year it was, but that will be easy to find.
I may remember it in just a moment here.
But Reverend Walker asked me to...
He saw my interest if I would help the...
In this organizing and training of children, especially younger people, because he wanted us to put a picket line in front of the library and ultimately in front of the Woolworth store downtown.
But we started with the library and I found a letter as a matter of fact because I became secretary to him, secretary of the NAACP.
And I had to therefore just really kind of be with him regularly in that work and handling the communication.
So I was trained, ended up training youngsters in the church to walk with picket signs and how...
And I had heard something of non-violence and we invited this young preacher from Montgomery, Alabama, Martin Luther King to come up to Petersburg, Virginia.
To speak for work because we now started having what we call mass meetings as well in Petersburg.
Reverend Walker had met Martin at a conference at Virginia Union University in Richmond, Virginia.
I remember he was telling me that. He had met him and now Reverend Walker is very much interested in what was going on in Montgomery, Alabama, the Montgomery Bus Boycott.
And invited this little preacher from Montgomery to come up and speak for us.
Reverend Dr. Martin Luther King did just that because in cities where there was a protest activity and it seemed to be just springing up all over the place, this protest activity.
And so now everybody had a mass meeting. We call them mass meetings. This is for some reason. Well, I think maybe it's obvious.
The mass meeting interested the meetings and all those cities and definitely in Petersburg, whatever where.
People were interested in coming to the mass meetings because they wanted to hear what was going on in town.
So they started coming to the mass meetings and when everybody now, massive numbers of people were hearing about the Montgomery Bus Boycott and Rosa Parks.
And when he came up to speak for us, Dr. King, I was on the program.
You know, when Black folks have programs with God, music and dancing and poetry and singing and everybody's involved, I used to try to tell the students at Cornell University when we pay all this money for a speaker to come.
And they just have the speaker walk up and very coldly give his speech and walk off with $10,000.
Put some flowers on the table. Let's have some music. Let's do something.
So maybe that's a cultural difference, I don't know. But I did poetry back to my love of poetry again.
I remember that we had dinner at the Parcinage at Reverend Walker's house.
And the young women's parish club was the organized group of women in the church that was hosting and planned the dinner and we were serving the dinner.
And I was moving around the table from the kitchen to the table. And Dr. King wanted to know, I can see him now sitting at the end of this quite long table in the Parcinage at Reverend Walker's house.
And he wanted to meet that young lady who said the poem on the program earlier that night.
Somehow the meal I think was after the program. And so I was identified. It was Dorothy Cotton who said the poem on the program.
And he wanted to meet me and I stood by the head of the table where he was sitting or maybe it was the foot of the table, one end of the table.
And I told him about the point. And we had a nice little chat. He was a user to me, very unassuming little guy, you know, rather short of statue.
As Correra used to say, she was not impressed when she saw him in terms of statue or anything like that. But there was still something very impressive about him.
And I enjoyed standing there chatting with him at the table because we were the young women's Paris Club. We were serving the meal.
While he was there in Petersburg, he was very much interested in what we would, our protest activity, picketing in front of the library.
And I had run the workshops, knew nothing substantive about non-violence. But I knew that you were not supposed to fight or hit anybody back. Very simplistic at that time.
But I'm helping the youngsters prepare to walk in front of the dime store, Woolworth store, and in front of the library.
But apparently before Dr. King left Petersburg, he asked Revan Walker to move to Atlanta. And while she walked, Revan Walker said, I will move to Atlanta to work with you as you are developing this organization, the Southern Christian Leadership Conference.
I'll move there and work with you. If I can take the two people who helped me here, that was a fellow named Jim Wood and me. If he could take us.
And so, while I Walker raised the subject with me and would I be interested in going, and I said to my husband, George Cotton, I told him this door. And I said, I'd like to go down and help them out for about three months.
And George was very quiet, didn't say very much. I'm not sure what he felt. I can summarize. Now, many, many, many years later, the pain it must have been for him because I went. George Cotton, my husband, drove me to Atlanta.
And Revan Walker was in the process of moving and I got to Atlanta and to stay my three months that I promised my husband. And George, as I said, drove me there. And would come down once or twice, he came down in the early months.
But I stayed 23 years. That the movement became my life once I, but that's how I got there. He's coming up to visit Dr. King, coming to visit us in Petersburg. And then my going going with to work with Revan Walker.
And ultimately becoming, I ended up being a director of education for SCLC.
Exactly. We'll turn to that. Just once I, one quick little question about the timing in Petersburg. It's not crucial. We could look this up easily enough. But you're, I believe the protest activity that you and in Petersburg and other folks carried forward out of the church in the Pittsburgh Improvement Association. That, that began in 59, I think.
Do you remember? I think the Greensboro City in February, 1960.
Oh, I'd have to look at the dates. It would be at the moment. That's okay. But I think you guys were even, you know, picketing in front of the Greensboro City. And then of course, after that, things really exploded.
I was not picketing in Greensboro. No, no, but you mean the movement, some movement people. Oh, yeah.
Oh, no, your, your pickets in front of the library and in front of wallboards.
Yeah, okay. Okay. Were those before?
Oh, I see what you, I'll see what you're saying. I'd have to, I'd have to research that. It's not a crucial thing. Yeah, I'd have to look at it.
But interesting question that you raised. Now I'm curious about it.
Tell me about, tell me about what you found when you arrived in Atlanta to join this organization called the Southern Fisheries Conference, which had only a very, very small step.
Well, it was just a warning, as they say. The Southern Christian Leadership Conference was, had not yet come into the big importance organization that we know it as we know it or came to know it.
I don't want to talk about today. That's another story.
But when I arrived, I remember, first I had to find a place to live in George Cotton, having driven me down my husband.
We stayed at a motel. I'm not sure which one for several days. And then George headed back to Petersburg, Virginia, where we were living.
And I remember focusing on a place to live. And I can talk about that. Ended up well.
I'm not sure which should come first, but maybe it doesn't matter.
Your question specifically was what I found when I got there. I found three or four people in an office on Albert Avenue.
And at least three people. And I only remember three people being there that I talk about.
Young woman, Lily Hunter. I can't believe I'm blocking on an elevator.
And the girl, woman named her, her name is Brown. Those were the three people in the office.
As I remember, I'm not sure when her name came on, but I think I found her there that she was working there.
But definitely, Ella Baker. And Lily Hunter had moved up from Montgomery as I understand.
I don't know where she is. I don't know if she's in custody. Are you familiar with her name? Okay.
Lily Hunter. Those were the three people there.
And of course, I'm this sort of wide eye. Youngster never traveled, having traveled much or lived in another city.
And I feel like I was exploring possibilities for my life. I feel like I was on a track to something different and new.
I didn't know what it was. I didn't know what the organization was. So I had a lot to learn.
But I have to include in my transitioning into Atlanta looking for a place to live and ended up staying for a few months with Dora McDonnell, who became Dora.
Oh, well, it was Dora working for him. I have to get the chronology straight here.
I lived with Dora's with Dora for a few months. I lived with, you know, I got a room in a house.
I will think of the woman's name quite. We call her everybody called her L and L. Doley.
But I had a room in her house in an elderly woman's house.
I'll think of the name. I'm going to have to call you up and give you the name.
So anyway, so it was a room there and ultimately a room in Dora's house.
I need to remember when Dora came on board. Dora must have already been there.
But I met her and she had a Dora had a house. And I ended up staying with Dora for a short time, I think just several months.
And you changed that to stay with Dora McDonnell, who became Dr. King's Secretary, and then staying with the elderly woman.
I hate saying elderly woman. I'll tell your name in a minute.
Thank you. My goodness. Oh dear. Now I'll have to take you to the White House too.
Yeah, Ms. Mosley, that's right. Stay with Ms. Mosley a longer. She was, how could I forget that?
Does anybody else forget?
No, we all forget. But the porch is a story. Yeah, it was Ms. Mosley.
Very recently. Right. I stayed with her. And I became quite at home there, but I just had a room.
But she made me feel very welcome. There were no children there and her son and his wife lived there.
So I lived with Ms. Mosley until I, again, see me just entering into life in Atlanta.
And eventually, not too long. Maybe I stayed with Ms. Mosley. I know she had how long maybe a year.
I got myself on an apartment and was shopping around for quite a while and found this apartment.
And by that time, of course, I'm enmeshing myself now in this growing organization, F-C-L-C.
And just kind of learning the ropes. Another thing I remember moving into Atlanta was during these weeks when I'm looking for a place to live.
I remember that first, as soon as George left, I was walking through an area.
And I remember fellow snatching my pocketbook, which I'd never got back, incidentally.
And now here, I'm this new, never traveled much at all. And having this happen, exploring, staying in these two or three different places, you know,
roaming with people. But Dora became, was Dr. King's secretary. I'm not sure when she became his secretary,
but I did have a room in her house for a while.
But she had been at Moorhouse?
I'm not sure. Would she have been, she might have worked there.
I thought she had come over from Moorhouse.
Maybe from Moorhouse. And was a very accomplished professional secretary with the E.C.
She was. She was. I have written that Dr. King said Dora could be secretary to the president of the United States.
And I wrote in my book manuscript that I'm doing. I hope that Dr. King told her that, that she could have been.
One thing we haven't mentioned as we're kind of coming through the late 50s and the early 60s, is that you would also just earn a master's degree.
So you would ride with a master's degree?
Yeah, I was doing a number of things, kind of simultaneously here.
What happened was, now, this is after the marriage, my marriage to George Codden, this was, and this was before going to SLC.
But yes, I went up to, I just, again, I knew that I was hungry for something and that something was on the horizon for me.
I can only put that in words now. But I said to my husband, I wanted to work on a master's degree.
And then I, so I went up to Boston, to Boston University for one summer, I think it was first.
And I came back home and then I realized I wanted to go back and really seriously pursue the degree, which I did.
I came home for a semester then went back, decided to stay and finish it.
So I did get the master's degree. As a matter of fact, that's one day I got clear about, because it was in the summer of 1960.
And I knew that I was questioning whether I would stay and march in Capungown in the commencement exercise to get this master's degree.
And decided that I would indeed do that, because it had been quite a struggle and working it into my, into my, working it into my, my schedule of things that were kind of cooking for me, things that were on my mind.
And in the summer of 1960, I, that's when I said to my husband, I want to go, I want to accept this invitation from Reverend Walker to go with him and the invitation from Dr. King to go to Atlanta.
So I went to Atlanta a few days after I got the degree at Boston University.
In an organization that, as you say, a warning in those, in those months, in the early 60s, such a small group of people, your original title on arrival, I think, was Director of Education.
Not originally. I was working as an administrator assistant to Reverend Walker. I went down there. And that's because we didn't know what we were going to be.
And I didn't even know that we were going to need, that we were going to have this education program. So I was working as Reverend Walker.
I remember saying to him, one day he was piling so much stuff on my desk and, and how, how, I'm a good type, fast typist. And we didn't have computers in those days.
So I'm sitting there typing and, and that one day I said, God, you expect me to finish this. This is so much, Reverend Walker on my desk. But I was his administrative assistant.
One, one story that stands out in my mind, or one event that stands out. For me is, one day, Dr. King pulled a chair up in front of my desk, because I'm sitting there with stuff all piled around my desk.
And, and it was almost like it was interviewing me and asking me a lot of questions about my life and family and school and whatever, just chatting.
And, short, they after that, he asked me if I would go over to a place called Highlander, a folk school, short, they after that.
And that's when I really kind of put two and two together and realized that I was really sort of being interviewed as I, some eyes.
And I'd have to tell you the whole story of Highlander, but I don't really need to do that except that Highlander was in the throes of being closed down because they had all sorts of phony charges leveled at them.
And, and I think that was the first time I've ever seen this communist school. And there was a, you may have heard of this billboard on the side of the road with Mrs. Ellen, the Roosevelt and Dr. King on the same roadside sign.
And, and somewhere in the caption was these have been to that communist school. Interestingly, one woman at, at Miles Horton, who founded Highlander, a folk school.
And, and the imperial service after he died, one woman said, told this story. And she said, we owe a big laugh at Miles' funeral. They wouldn't have done communism from rheumatism.
Because, they're calling the school a communist school. And then, because, you know, Miles Horton was, we had like folk and white folk meeting together when that was just not the thing to do in those days.
But I was asked to go over to Highlander. And because Dr. King and company must have seen the handwriting on the wall. The state was just, they were just taught it all the time and charge and just had many charges leveled against them, including selling whiskey.
And I understand that they had served beer at, at an event there, the Highlander folk school. And the Highlander folk school is another, you know, a whole story.
But when Dr. King asked me if I would go over there to just meet the people and check out the school to get to know something of the school, I did just that.
So now I'm moving away from being an administrative person to Reverend Whitey Walker. I went to Highlander and I met this woman and Septimal Clark. And because Septimal was working there at the Highlander folk school.
There's an interesting story about how she got to work there. I'll see if I can summarize this. But Septimal had met Issa Jenkins.
Issa Jenkins was a man who lived on the John's Island, you know, the Sea Islands off the coast of Charleston. And Issa had, I think I've been told more than one, but he used to drive a school, old school bus he had acquired from the islands to the mainland of Charleston.
And taking people back and forth to work is very enterprising man. And he would take a little break for the telephone.
There you go. Okay, we're back after a short break. Talk about Issa Jenkins.
Yes, I, when I did go over to Highlander and I met Septimal Clark there. Septimal Clark had met Issa Jenkins who had a little transportation service bringing people, taking people back and forth to work from John's Island to Charleston back and forth.
And John's Island stands out in my mind some of the other islands, Ward, Maloe, the other islands off the coast of Charleston, ultimately were involved.
But I really want to tell you about, I'd like to share the fact that Issa Jenkins experienced an event, he didn't see it.
Well, let me tell you what the event was. A white man shot a black young boy. And the white man shot the boy because the boy accidentally ran over the man's dog.
So he just killed the boy. And understand the dog really ran out in front of the truck, I think it was. And so, but the white man killed the boy, this black boy.
And the people predominantly African American and literally African American, you can still hear the well of language they call it spoken around the island there in those days.
And Issa realized that something was wrong with that picture because the people of John's Island didn't rise up and righteous indignation when this man decided to just shoot the boy and nothing happened.
And Issa was smart enough to know that they didn't didn't protest this killing because the boy, because the people of, they didn't protest the killing because the people on the island had no political power.
What I've just said really is the germ of the citizenship education program that ultimately came my job because what happened was Issa started helping people on, on his old, his bus as he drove them back and forth to work, understand why it was important for them to register to vote and talking to them about political power.
And it's amazing that Issa, well, since this, knew this, understood this and its relationship to an event like that. And the septum of Clark said, Issa Jenkins had a third grade education, but a PhD mind.
And I like to quote that because it must be true he could see that the people having no political power and the people on the island also were predominantly functionally illiterate on the island there.
But Issa met septum of Clark. Her story also relates to my going to, as you'll see, in the sense that septum had been fired from the Charleston school, school system. She had been a teacher, but she was fired because she would not say whether or not she was a member of the NAACP or not.
And they met Issa Jenkins and septum of met actually had a conference at the Highlander folk school.
So we can just sort of actually, I guess, is a fast forward a little bit here to a time when the citizenship education program that is helping functionally illiterate black folk, African American people understand their political power.
It just grew like tops. It was in septum and Issa met each other there at the Highlander folk school. Issa was wanting people to discover their political power and literacy training was a major part of that.
And then meeting this teacher who loved to, there's a photograph of septum of Clark holding an elderly gentleman's hand helping him learn to do cursive writing.
Because in those days, one had to do cursive writing to sign your name, and which was probably a trick too to just to keep black folk from registering to vote.
So my being there meeting septum of who now moved came over from Charleston to work there at the Highlander folk school in Issa and her and septum of working together now.
I just want to tell you that for Highlander was fighting for its very life in the courts at this time, and they lost that battle. In other words, the state confiscated that property.
Beautiful property there in the cumulon mountains. And because they lost that property, so Highland in terms of location was kind of in limbo for a while, maybe one way to speak about that.
But ultimately they got a new property, which is just beautiful in the mountains in that area. I should be able to describe it more directly.
And can I have written about it in my book manuscript. But now that they were in the time between the time from actually losing the Highlander folk school, the people who were funding these workshops now that septum and use septum of work.
So septum could help them learn to read and write. And is always talking the political aspect of it.
Everybody wanted to make sure this training continued. SCLC now, my organization, Dr. King's organization inherited the organization.
The Marsha Field Foundation who gave the major funds to the Highlander school to run do this training, helping these black folk learn to reading, write enough so they could register and vote.
They were interested in keeping this training program going for these people. And eventually, not eventually.
It didn't take them long to decide they would give those funds to SCLC to run this citizenship education program. And I was asked to become the director of citizenship education program.
Thanks to Andrew Young, who also Andrew Young had secured through the good offices of his church, the congregational church, a facility there in Macintosh, Georgia.
And we would hold workshops there. And now, Andy, September and I would travel the south, recruiting people to come into the five day residence of workshop.
Because what happened after we could probably point to a number of horrible events now around the south. But we knew that we could do more with this training program than just help people learn to read and write.
We could expand it to helping them understand their political rights. They could understand that their rights as a citizen, what that all meant.
Because Andy had a connection with the congregational church, being a congregational minister, we found this, the Dorchester Center at Macintosh, Georgia, and appropriated the national church owned.
So we started having workshops there. But now, in vision, September, Maclark, Andrew Young, and I traveling the south. And we would target places where protest activity was springing up everywhere.
And we would go into places that were just kind of hot beds of activity now. And we would tell people we have this five day residence of workshop. And we would invite them to come to Dorchester Center.
And they would have a wonderful experience because we know you're fighting for your rights here. And we will help you discover ways to do that.
I remember sitting in someone's living room, actually in North Virginia. And my friend, Eunice Menis, and Albert Menis, the husband, hosted me because I had met Eunice Menis a teacher when I was doing my student teaching before I graduated from college.
And Eunice invited me to her house, and her husband sat there. And so Al said, you made a wonderful talk, Dorothy.
But if you're going to tell these people, invite these people to come to your five day workshop. And because when I finished telling them, then I said, and we'll pay your way.
He said, you did that backwards. And now, Albert Menis described himself as a junk man because he really did sell parts of old cars. His wife was a teacher.
But he would, and it was interesting. He had, I think, had a lot of fun calling himself a junk man. This junk man told me how to do my selling of the notion of the invitation to come away with us to Dorchester Center.
And so tell them first that you're going to pay that way because while you're talking, they're sitting there thinking, I can't afford to go anywhere. I can't take a trip. If they know you're going to pay that way up front.
So I thought, here's this junk man telling me with the master's degree, how to recruit people, and how to make my little speech to invite them to come. So anyway, I have a lot of fun with that.
Tell me about Andrew. Tell me about Septimal Clark. Tell me about Bernie Sravitz.
Well, Septimal was, incidentally, Septimal and especially Septimal and Andy and I used to, well, we would, the three of us in a car.
And I think people would sometimes think we were mother, son, and daughter. Septimal being the elder, you know, in the car. But we would go from city to city, but we would target one place and we would go.
Septimal, because there was a spirit about her that was just a warm and she was sort of the grandmother type.
I have an image of what that is. I don't know if people hearing that coming from me now would necessarily know, but people know grand grand motherly in the sense of what grandmothers used to look like.
But now when I see somebody and they tell me they have grandmother, they have grandchildren. I think they look like they're 29. You are a grandmother.
But in a way, the grandmother type had a different connotation in those days. You know, you were older, you walked slower and you didn't dance. But grandmothers, I know now, I have a friend who's a grandmother. She lays down a mean, she's a grandmother.
But so we were in the car and Septimal still focused on this, this is her part of the teaching that we would do. Septimal focused on the handwriting, because in a lot of places you had to do, one had to know cursive writing in order to register.
I think it was just a trick to actually exclude black folk. And there were massive numbers of African American people across the Southland especially and other places too. But we were focusing across the South.
But if they could do block, or make block letters, that wouldn't do. You have to do cursive writing. Septimal was very good at that. There's a photograph of Septimal holding an elderly gentleman's hand helping him learn to do cursive writing.
Andrew and I also had a particular focus. We came to play a particular role in the five day residence of workshops. Now inviting folk to come to the Dorchester Center at McIntosh, Georgia.
And I would plan the five day sessions. And Andy would get into the politics. I remember one session. The main session, Andy did was actually pushing people to understand. As we all did that, but why voting was important. And even I used to name the session when I would write out the outline of the week's work. Why one vote matters. And Andy would tell the story.
I'm forgetting which president won because one vote made a difference. And so your vote counts. Andy wanted to emphasize the fact that one vote matters. And I remember so vividly and is doing that session.
And I remember that I was in the process of bringing Robinson also was in the urging people to understand the politics as I was as well. But I laid out the five day sessions. And we were I got people to work with the people who came with it has to be understood that these were sometimes functionally illiterate people, but who are active in their communities.
And I got invited to come. And but we also had people who were sort of itinerary preachers or preachers like anyway, my dad has an interesting description. I think I mentioned earlier about who some of these preachers were. But they would also come to workshops. And I had to in the workshop help them understand what it meant to have a dialogue going between all the people and not just beat up on people because you were the preacher.
Because especially those the black communities from which a lot of the people came were if you call yourself a preacher, people felt like they had to be quiet if the preacher spoke.
But sometimes they knew more than the preacher. I don't mean to to integrate you know to but but the preachers had to learn what it meant what the ways people learn, for example.
And that people needed to feel encouraged and and they didn't need to feel that they had to shut up because somebody who called himself a preacher was speaking.
But also there were there were also good men of the cloth.
Let me ask a couple questions about the for more detail about the about the five day training.
I read that that you made a very careful point to rather than say to lecture from the front of the room a set of specific lessons we want to understand right to start conversation.
Of course.
So out of the group's conversation would develop a more focused understanding of the things that the attendees wanted to know.
I have a very interesting still is interesting to me. I don't know if this would be maybe it's included in what people call the socratic method of teaching.
But there's one one incident that I've anecdote that I've written about something that happened in in a session with me.
And in the discussion. I was having people share some of what was going on in their communities. And I remember one woman like why were they there? What were you concerned about?
And one woman told me that every time she went down to no this was all African American folk black folk if one wants to use that term.
Every time I go down to the courthouse the clerk the city clerk would just be so insulting and I was trying to tell her that they would the people who would test the well water would test all the white folks water but would not test the water in my well.
And I remember the second day she again was so energized and just stirred about the fact that they would test everybody's well water but the water for black folk.
And the third day she's ready to tell me that same story again and I said well why aren't you the city clerk?
And I love telling that story because it really makes the point of how there was this there's no such thing as an audible silence but the other ways to describe the energy in the room at that moment.
And the transformation obviously that was happening with not only her but because that's why they were there to decide that they were not going to be victims anymore but incident that that's I'm using a part of that language in the title of the book that I'm doing.
And Dr. King came to close out one of the workshops for me I called him and said would you please come the if your backs not bent the movement from victim to victory.
Now I called him over it and I said could you come over to Savannah to do it just a center and close out we've had about six to people here for the five days and they have been just a wonderful powerful group and we need you we would like you to come and just do the closing because we have a little band quitted on the last day a band quit put together about people go out and get green stuff off of the trees and the bushes and the food was a little fancier and we fancy up the room and the people in the workshop would do that.
But anyway Dr. King came over and I remember his telling the people and he has used this terminology or had used it more than once but he said to the to the now about to be graduates of our citizenship education workshop.
Nobody can ride your back if your backs not bent a metaphor I hope people will get that as they see my book but I decided that was what we were doing at the woman who was complaining that the city clerk treated her so badly you know you can be feel sorry for yourself or what was been the rest of your life angry or you can become the city clerk and nobody can ride your back if your backs not bent and the subtitle the movement from victim to victory.
What would you say among you you had what five or six thousand people trained in these workshops maybe more I've heard and to use the term eight thousand I don't know how I don't know how we kept I but at least between five and eight I say between five and six and the things it was about eight thousand who came through the years because ever and then we would we would recruit people and people would go back to their home communities and tell others about the training.
We had a training workshop which we held every convened every month and and then other people would come and it was very it was very powerful the experience and had I remember once you know singing was so important in the civil rights movement and I remember I love to sing even though I you know I don't read a note of music people ask me what key do you want to do.
I start looking in my pocket I don't know what key what what do you mean what key but what I want to tell you the and one bus load was going back I think we had recruited a lot of people from the Delta area Mississippi a fan of Lou Hamer living in in ruralville Mississippi and she came more than once and once fan of Lou Hamer had come to a workshop she would we could just tell her give her the dates of the next workshop.
And and she would do the recruiting there and she became really quite a regular but I do remember that a bus load was going back to I think it was a Delta Mississippi and and I remember that Andy young and I stood on the grounds because they had come by bus she was it was mostly a group from the Delta Mississippi at this point so therefore the bus and we stood there as the bus was rolling out and and I started singing.
This may be the last time I'm going to cross I better stop this may be the last time children this may be the last time it may be the last time I don't know because it may be the last time because people may get killed a few people did but but I remember standing on the ground as the bus was pulling off singing it may be the last time we worked together it may be the last time I don't know.
And we both cried as the bus pulled off.
Let me ask a question about about these years early 60s coming in all this work with slightly different angle perspective because you were you were a woman right at the center of the SCLC world probably with more I think fair to say more status and institutional authority inside the SCLC.
I don't believe I thought about the gender issues initially and I'm not sure that that the role of the SCLC is not the same as the other one.
I don't believe I thought about the gender issues initially and I'm not sure that that ever became the overriding factor for me early on.
I think that I evolved as as we all did in perhaps as I'm sure as many women did and may and perhaps a few men we we were all growing and evolving into new definitions of ourselves and our role.
I think that since the women's rights movement didn't happen to in the 70s and it was very interesting that in the large measure we would sort of first go along with the paradigm of the time the pattern of the time I think.
For example I could be and almost always was the only woman at the table in an executive staff meeting and if they needed coffee guess who they would ask to get the coffee if they needed somebody to take notes you know women were secretaries and I did that until a man on the staff Jack O'Dell I'll never forget it was Jack O'Dell who said Dr. King d'Arth and he used to stay at this table because we're talking about what I'm going to do.
We're talking about whatever we were talking about at that time and Jack O'Dell just sent me a book he's just written and but and I am just recently back in touch with him we're going to do a program together I think it's in New Orleans soon.
But Jack O'Dell said I needed to stay at the table he was more attuned to the changing time than I was but I felt I had power even though some of the men maybe didn't recognize it or maybe saw me as you know just the woman at the table.
And I don't know if I even felt that I felt that I knew I had an important job I had an important role to play and I knew that I was smarter than some of those guys at the table but it's not something you talk about you just sort of know it and somewhere along the way I developed a real confidence in who I was and I just let them be who they thought they needed to be.
And because Dr. King of course you know being at the table he's a head guy in charge of the whole organization but not very not very I don't want to say an articulate but verbose is what like we could have a big debate going on at the table at the and our senior staff meetings and I described Dr. King as being very focused on.
Listening to the debate you as to whether we should go this place or that place or whatever the discussion was at the table at a given time Dr. King was a great listener to all of these he called us I'm not sure I was included in that his team of wild horses and so this team of wild horses for example I remember sitting next to Dr. King as Jose Williams on our staff walked into the the table at the table.
And he was going to do the executive staff meeting late and Dr. King hunched me and said watch this meeting turn into a fight now that Jose is here he didn't say so they could hear but he wanted I heard it and I was like we were just so on the same kind of wavelength here and Jose a verb from Bunches God did come in he was arguing for more budget because he was in charge of the field staff and he needed most of the money and whatever it was he was a Jose would bring a special kind of a fighting energy.
And they were other you know guys at the table you know so I'm so certain tack kinds of guys who were there were you know CTV and and well I don't need to call you know all their names James Bevel who were who were overalls and a little a beanie of a hat and and a bunch of guys at the table who were arguing we you know debating things like shall we respond to an invitation to go to this place or to the table.
So I'm going to go to this place or that place or whatever you know was on the agenda.
Well this doesn't necessarily an incident I'd like to mention I remember the James Meredith March when we heard about it the phone rang and someone said we knew James Meredith was going to do that he had let people know us know a lot of that he was going to start his march against fear across Mississippi.
We got that message sitting in the staff meeting and I remember that that when someone came in to give us that message I remember Dr. King fell it or taking charge he was he was more often silent until he needed to speak interestingly as I really reflect on it but we stopped that meeting and we had to miss a little bit of the conversation.
And we had to miss a city to continue the march after the shot now this was after some of the folks on our team had talked about the silliness of going over starting the march by yourself in Mississippi and you know he was threatened and he was shot but there was no debate when Dr. King said we're going to Mississippi and to support his effort.
Tell me a little more about your relationship with Dr. King just that because you would be close professional associates across that whole span and I would imagine that there was far more spirit and connection among that group of persons who built and made SCLC obviously than just the just you know coming to the office.
Obviously so much more than all of them.
Well I'm not sure what you mean but maybe I do you said then just coming to the office.
Obviously this wasn't just a regular this is something so different than some regular job where you would have to say.
Well yeah well I think a movement a movement I know what you're getting at.
But a movement is not like going into an official office on the 13th floor of elevator whatever and going into your formal meeting a movement as I understand it as I know it had to be different if you if you were formal.
To me I mean it wouldn't work I don't know how one could have a movement yeah I know people think the would up and whisper about a personal relationship but is that oh you raise your eyebrows yeah well no but I know that there are people who suspect I felt I think he was my best friend and I felt such a rapport with him and I think he with me as well he felt well you know being woman I guess it would be a little bit different because he didn't go anywhere without and either he felt so close.
It was almost like Martin Andy, Bernard Lee it was almost like he didn't want to go anywhere without us so I was always with him I was most all the time with him as as Andy was and and Bernard what else could I say but your question is right on because I your question makes me feel and realize I was always with him.
I feel and realize that as I could as I compare with being running a bunch of programs under the in Atlanta with you know some federal agency which I belong with.
Right right right going into an office like that which which I did was was quite different than being in the throws of a social change movement I remember for example in
oh where were we in Birmingham I think I remember running across the street barefoot to take some food to people because they had put people in a thin-stained area because there was no more space in the jails and it was not it was not a
coating tie situation unless we needed to do that for a particular reason so I did feel a very special closeness and relationship with him I felt like he was friend and I could be friend or I would tell you something that I really don't want on tape but for
for yeah I know you I know you are I think it might be already even if I say that because I remember one night that we were having gin and tonic for example that's all that's all I'm talking about I mean for five of us and I remember that he's tasted my gin and tonic I mean that is good but just Jonathan what you make me another one of these gin top you know but you know the well almost the phonon is of some preacher I imagine
God rest his soul my grandfather I don't know if he ever you know that alcoholic beverage is worth that you know sinful and all that foolishness some of them who preach that enjoy it even moonshine probably because it had any money to but but I mean we would have that kind of time together I remember even being in you were very close I remember being in we were in Paris France
a stopover having gone to Oslo Norway for the Nobel Prize and I remember our being in gathered in a hotel with somebody I guess Dr. Kim must have had a suite because we were all gathered in the room once and he wanted he had heard that there was an African American person who had a soul food restaurant you know what's
Southern soul food is like you and he wanted so I said you you come all the way to Paris France and you want some colored greens and pork chops and when you're in Paris and I you know so we just had a big laugh and I still
to me that's the right I don't know the ridiculous this up but I mean I felt that close to him we were friends and you know and they was we were all we were friends and we were we were like we had to be like a family outside of the you know blood relatives I'm sure why does must have must have well of course on a trip like that everybody you know if you have a wife your wife was there husband but that
except that sometimes when we were flying together there were like I don't know maybe 18 19 or 20 people I'm looking at a photograph there while we're going heading to Oslo and and Dr. Kim's wife Kareta was on one plane and Dr. Kim was on another plane we in other words the group was divided they never flew on the same plane on a trip like that they had four children to raise and if anything
should happen at least one parent and but I was on the plane with Dr. Kim and and also his mother was on the same plane as I was and and I remember Mrs. Albert King Dr.
Kim's mother started singing she touched me on the shoulder and said Dorothy look over there the sun's coming up and and there's a song we have a song gosh we have a song about everything's oh day
on the come day oh day on the come day oh day on the come day they done broke in a mouth so young to come day young to come day now
now mama Mrs. King is singing that I didn't call them Mama King so we called that again dad again so she stood up in the island started singing and Dorothy I was sitting next to her
the wind the sun's coming up and that that brought the song to mind for her before we sat down Dr. Kim was up in the
aisle singing it's all I'm just saying we had a lot of foolishness and a lot of fun you know we were friends
together we were people together we were and and he loved to sing too I have a picture of him with his hands
in his pocket and his head thrown back and he I don't know what we were singing at that point but he was
really enjoyed singing he enjoyed the music and he thought I was a pretty good singer but but that was
but just the way we were together was when he would go he'd love to go to Jamaica some warm
climate to write I remember we were in he loved to go he went to Bermany once and I think we were in
Jamaica and when this happened when you got word that you know guess who called him a notorious
liar head of the FBI when you heard that J. Edgar Hoover had called him the most notorious liar that was
the first time I saw him cry I saw tears run down it's cheap when when J. Hoover called him a notorious
liar and we were down the end it was there Bernan Lee trying to think with anybody else I think
Coretta came later but we were sitting around eating I'm not sure how we got the message except
probably newspapers somebody had handed us wherever we were staying there but we would go with him when
he would he loved to go to the islands to write and and and then I had to comfort him because it was
just so painful for him I mean but he didn't hang in there long at that that moment but that was
very painful for him and and all of us so I'm just thinking of how we were together we couldn't have
had a better friendship or couldn't have been closer another time thinking speaking of friendship there
was a staff meeting going on in Atlanta and I had flew I think it was the reason I was home and
had not gone down to Ebenezer Church for the meeting and they were debating whether this was going
to be about his making the speech against the Vietnam War in that meeting the staff talk about a
bunch of random bookish guys who were you should do you this you shouldn't do that and he would sit there
very often and just listen to all the energetic conversation but when Dr. King would open his mouth
to speak everybody would shut up and I'm very conscious of that that what a listener he was and
just you know pulling whatever he could pull from the various you know parts of the conversations and
he when when he was ready to say something yeah there was kind of a quiet but in that particular
meeting I want to tell you he left the meeting at one point he became a little I'm not sure how to
describe it but guess what he got and I'm not in the meeting he came up to my apartment and it was
he was giggly like a child he said he told me they were arguing about whether he should speak out
against whether he should make that speech and he was sort of laughing it was really that's why I
say it was kind of giggly like a child he came over and just sat there and I'm not sure how he
left or how much we talked we didn't go into any detail but he just told me what was going on
I mean he sat in that chair I never ever I still think of him sometimes I think of I've
written about it he said it is goal rocking chair in my living room and and and talk to me but
another time he sat in that chair was yeah some some criticism it wasn't the over it may have
been during this same period it may have been after I wish I could remember the exact time that he
sat there because at that point another time that I'm remembering him sitting in my apartment he was
he was thinking about pondering what he should do you you may have I'm a lot of people I've heard
that he was really distressed and tired in the end towards the end of his life that he was just
we didn't know it was the end of his life but that he was really weary many people have spoken about
his being almost in the state of depression and I don't use the word depression but I know that he
was weary probably just weary of the battle just weary and I remember his telling me again sitting
in this chair I don't think it was the same time that maybe I should take a sabbatical maybe I should
somebody had offered him a position at a university in I think somewhere in England maybe I should
take should accept a position in other words maybe I should just stop for a while I wish I knew the
date because then we could you know I could see how close it was to the date that he really did
go on to the great beyond but he was he was pondering whether he should continue in other words the
exhaustion the distress about the increasing criticism coming at him even from movement people
and you know we could some eyes you know a lot of reasons that people were criticizing him
even the youngsters as I call them Stokely Carmichael and Company who were really talking about the
uselessness of the non-violent approach to bring it about social change and I remember sitting
at a table in his kitchen with some of the people from SNCC student nonviolent coordinating committee
sitting around the table but especially Stokely I'm not sure who else with Stokely was sitting
there but I was at the table and this is like in his kitchen around his kitchen table and and Dr.
King loved this kind of dialogue and Stokely was sharing with him you know his thoughts that you
know maybe we should try some other approaches this this wasn't said at that table but Dr. King loved
dialoguing about people I remember Stokely they like talking about France's been on and some
of a writers and that they would quote and trying to prove to Dr. King that we should try some other
approaches but I remember ultimately Dr. King said and I think this was on the speech not at the
table that was a more informal dialogue around the kitchen table but it is recorded Dr. King said
if I am the last lone voice speaking for nonviolence that I will do and even if he couldn't get
other people to really understand that you know the end we seek is pre-existent in the means we use
the end we seek is pre-existent in the means we use he really believed that and I know he believed
that and he lived that and I think that many people I don't know how many but people were weary
like folk were tired of struggling even though there had been some victories and civil rights
built in others but I think that maybe the culture the people in mass were transitioning to another
way of thinking about our fight for for desegregation well for working to break down what I called our
American son of part eight that people were weary as well as Dr. King but he he never gave up on the
fact that nonviolence was the way the end we seek is pre-existent in the means we use he really
believed that did you have an opinion a strong opinion one way or the other time about his decisions say
to speak out and be a non knowing what all the ramifications that that's all the position of it
the the same I don't remember a lot of debate but I do know that he didn't it never occurred to him not
to do it and what I just shared even on the heels of this discussion because there were people on
the board of directors that was a family friend a Marion Logan signed a letter which we don't
think she wrote and the letter urging him not to do that and you know my sense was and and maybe his
too you know what does she know how come she thinks she knows more whether he should speak out
against the war or not but he never what I just quoted in terms of his saying I find the last
lone voice actually that was sort of at the end of all this dialogue about as to whether he
should speak out against the war or not and when the the letter came and I think he was more
committed to to saying what he really felt he was more committed than then then maybe then before
because once the criticism and then the advice not to do so I think that strengthened him in his
belief he would just be quiet go into the silence as as is often said and and come really clear
what his response would be and it was just what I've said did you have did you ever have
the close circle around and you personally did you ever have specific animations that
that you know threats were pressing him very close to him that could excuse me yeah did you ever
have knowledge of specific fears and worries about it comes on his life yeah but I think that
we do the threats were coming fast and furiously the threats on his life but they were not so
overt I guess is the term the threats were not so overt that we would would
um even consider stopping our work or or creating a different plan I remember that I
could feel more anxious if somebody's running up to him to one in an airport for example as we
were always going somewhere and I remember that I was more nervous about the person running towards
him than he he I don't think he was nervous at all but those of us around him um I have a sense
that Dr. King had accepted that he might go out in a violent way because there was that kind
of hatred abroad in the land but I I can't believe that it was an operating um consciousness
with him because I would I would step closer to him when somebody was running in an airport to
shake his hand then he's ready he's got his hand out and he's ready to to shake hands with the person
it didn't control his behavior at all I think it was those of us around him I remember once and
it can tell you this of you if you're going to talk with him that um and if we were having a big
march I'm not thinking of which one it was at this moment but Andrew surrounded him with a lot of
guys that and the thought looks like Martin that looked like him because then people if they shot
you know they won't get our leader but Andrew was conscious of that we were more than Dr. King was
um but Andrew got all these guys and look and and the Chuckles when he talks about they don't
know why I put them up around Dr. King it wasn't because they were important it was because they
would take the bullet and not Martin would take you know it was that sort of thing so it didn't
the threats didn't control our lives so uh no no he is sorry yeah
okay we're back we're back after short break um it's kind of I want to ask about your reflections on
the very very challenging transition after the incestination and um very difficult obviously for me to
imagine what that loss must have been but I wonder how looking back from this long distance now what
how do you how do you make your way forward how did I make my way forward um I'm conscious of a statement
that one young man who was on our team at some point um after three years I remember this young
guy who worked with us kind of late in the SCLC movement I remember his observing you all are
coming out of mourning now this was after three years and I didn't know that uh he saw us
as in mourning but clearly you know there were not a lot of words around that there's some things
that are so feeling so deep and have such an impact that uh words just don't seem to
do the right words don't seem to come easily to describe to describe it but it was like we not only lost
our need or we lost our inspiration we lost our um best friend some of us knew him as a best friend um
um so I remember well I could talk about a lot of things some of which um are very painful to talk
about in the sense that for example Reverend Avenue that became was was vice president and
Reverend Avenue um the vice president walks into the seat of the presidency right and um
I remember just feeling just sort of staring in the space almost I couldn't relate to to even that
change not to cast an aspersion necessarily but then but maybe so too I think it was almost
unfair to Reverend Avenue to to tell him he is now president uh I may have shared with you the
Dr King sometimes called us this team of well horses in a loving kind of way but you know just
arguing and and really into our part of the work and and we were just giving all of our lives and
our energy to the part of the work you know one guy you know if you talk to CT Vivian when one
guy organizing preachers all over the south and and uh you know and Jose and when he's both
education and even even though I might have wanted to put him in a trunk and sit on it sometimes
but I also loved Jose you know you know in a special kind of way like you're naughty your
Rembukes his brother um but but so having all of that uh energy now uh well I think nobody knew
what to do with that with what we were left with and what we were left with was an incredible
void that nobody could fill what what is clear to me is that you know you know I could look out
among among the team the SCLC staff and I could eventually for example here um and uh saying he's
going to run for for for mayor um I looked out I can reflect back and think that um the reason
I actually was Andrew Young my good friend ended till this day um you know I really
honor him for being in size of enough to know that I needed to do something else and one day
he got word that the people in Birmingham Alabama needed a head start director and this is three
years after Dr. Kings death and Andy said uh they they need a temporary director why don't you go over
and work with him for it and I didn't read but I did it so readily and so easily so I
end to solve something that I'm walking around like I'm trying to do my work but I needed to do
something else and Andy saw that I think and suggested that I go over and and feel this the
head start director had left to see me London some kind of cloud or something uh in Birmingham and
but so I went to Birmingham I just left and one reason it was easy to leave um I didn't
it wasn't SCLC as I had known it it wasn't the same energy I hate to say this about
Reverend Avenue I said but I do think it was unfair of him because I think he too was in over his
head in terms of leading this quote unquote team of wild horses that was Reverend Avenue there was a
wonderful preacher and a loving caring minister to his flock I remember a story and I write about
it in my book how the the we were there was um I don't know if it was a march but he the there
was some blockade and we were not supposed to go past the blockade but the police managing that
blockade saw that this was Reverend Ralph Avenue and now president of SCLC so they were going to let
him through but nobody else I think we were going to a meeting at the church and and Reverend
Avenue after said well I won't go unless you let the people behind me go because they are the
members of my choir they are the members of my my church and they need to get and he negotiated
so that the police would not just let him through but I'm just he was just a caring and there was
very sensitive to that but I don't think Reverend Avenue could could have led that team of wild
horses I keep using that term because as Dr. King called us in a very loving kind of way it wasn't
he was like throwing in the you know water above his head as the sand goes something like that so
Pete and I was talking about running for this is after I don't know maybe three years and it will
remember the exact date but and I'm going over to Birmingham and and not only did I go to be the
head start director for Jefferson County I took an apartment over there and it was like
it felt good to be out of that office and the reason it felt good and my office was right I could
hear conversations if the doors were open between the president's office where Dr. King said
and my office running the Citizens of Education program and and I heard Ralph say through the
doors one day I hate to say this but I think I'm going to say it I heard him say to someone on the
phone well I would do whatever he was talking about but I don't have anybody to help me and I
remember that I had tears in my eyes because he didn't have anybody to help him because you can't
help somebody if you don't know what they're doing or what they want to do it's not a put down it's
just that I think that you know I remember Jesse I don't I heard they want to mention Jesse in the
midst of all of this but I was going to say a staff member came to have a talk with the president of
SCLC and and and Ralph what make that somebody else because this is what he oh dear can't you can't
unsay something and Ralph would sort of in a giggly silly kind of way make the person wait when
they weren't waiting for anything because he was in over his head is my sense oh gosh where are
you going to play this do you what I'm just saying what I'm trying to say and trying not to say
sure you've written that the non-violence that really coming into an understanding of the
the philosophy of non-violence have changed you it had given a place a means to reposition what
had been anger into a different kind of feeling and you wrote that I read that you're writing that
that did he change you did did a violent death of dr. Keane did that change you in any
fundamental way absorbing that kind of a boil and watching having watched from such a close
vantage point all the violence that was just visited upon so many more participants did it change you
in any way I still believe in the philosophy and way of non-violence I still believe it is
the way you're at many levels I don't believe that having
or have the violence intensify or spread I don't think it would have changed the society we
broke down a vicious system in this country I call it American style apartheid I don't think we
could have I think we would have had many many more deaths and maybe there those who would argue I
wonder what my mom would say that would have been many more deaths that we decided that we were
going to fight it out violently I don't believe that that would have moved us to the end that we
were seeking the thing is we were very clear about the end we were seeking we were very clear about
our goal which was to change this vicious system in this country and this isn't original with me but
but as someone has observed racist the deep kind of racism that we faced is a
sickness and the end of says there's a lot I've heard the end of say it much really more than once
but it's a sickness and when people are sick you work to heal them I still believe that you if
they're sick you need to heal them and just a quick little reference back to my dad I think the
times that he would like take off a strap to beat us he didn't know any better but today I beg I
wish I had a chance now I could change his behavior if I related to him and approached him from
a loving understanding of what he was about now the racism as we face it was vicious it was hard
but I can't think of a way that would have changed the system that would have saved massive numbers
of lives even we could almost count the folk who were killed you know on you know a couple of
two or three hands perhaps that might be slightly exaggerated but I think there would have been
many many more deaths and that was those who would argue that that would be okay I think some of
the people I used to hear Stokely say well I'll try non-violence but if non-violence doesn't work
take up the gun that was a frame and he would keep saying take up the gun I had a chance to talk
with us Stokely he came here to speak not long before he died and and and I challenged him around
some things that he said one being the only way for women in the movement was prone and and of
course he had a lot of women to hold that against him even now and he said well I was joking
but but his refrain take up the gun again here speaking at Cornell he said
yeah he said it again and I had a chance to say Stokely tell me who you going to shoot and I don't
remember an answer for him but who would you shoot and if he had answered it's like it's so if
you shoot you know name somebody so that's going to bring you the goal towards the goal you have
said but if your goal isn't clear you can do anything okay shoot but have you have you
moved closer to your purpose to your goal I mean that's one of the ways I'd like to talk about it
and I think one understands loving a developing a loving caring feeling in oneself
if one pays attention and gives some energy to that and that it just feels better to win the
the violent one the unloving one the two ones calls it feels better to bring about that kind
of transformation than to just beat them up in return it I think it's not simplistic it's not
easy even really to talk about it I don't think but I but I do try to talk about it and I do believe
that it would that it does non-violence it does create it moves me closer to the kind of world I
want to live in and I am willing now to even explore with someone who is mean and wants to be violent
and vicious I'm willing to explore with them what their goal is in life and even though they
hold to it if they would dialogue I would like still like to to be in dialogue with them now you
know somebody some people want to ask about what's the bad guy who just our president just
ordered folks to go forward and kill the quote unquote bad guy I guess they want to hear
those of us who espoused want to talk about non-violence are you saying that you you would
have taken out Osama bin Laden and and I thought about that a lot and I don't I don't argue
against that when I look at what the fall I would have been this probably is not relevant to
what you want to talk about but but I did think about the fact that it was discovered that he
apparently had plans to derail planes trains and killed many more people that he had
I think and I never knew that I could say that but I find myself reflecting on that now if he
is going to derail some trains and bring down some more planes maybe he needed to be taken out
in other words I don't criticize Osama our president for for giving the order to let it go
forward that doesn't take away my general basic belief in non-violence tell me about maybe
you've been so generous with your time and I don't want it just completely exhaust even though
in a perfect world we could talk for days because it's such interesting such interesting history
and you were right in the middle so much of it tell me about the nature of countries
well and your vision for what you really like to do happen well first of all know that I didn't
start it it wasn't my idea but when someone came to me and and this is exactly how I have two
friends came up on K. Wessels who's a teacher's over at Cornell runs a wonderful program there
the Center for Transformative Action on K. Wessels and another person and colleague of mine came
to my house and said the on K. says she got the idea of starting a Dorothy Cotton Institute
she had the number of programs under her organization as kind of the umbrella organization
and she's based at Cornell but runs a special program there sort of housing for for a number of
programs they came to me and since on K. came to me and said she got this idea in the shower one day
and and said to her husband or or two people I have this idea that that we could use Dorothy
Cotton's legacy and after and so I sat listening to them there around my little kitchen table
and I said well okay I'm not going to do it I mean I can't see myself doing it but it was
like an answer to a prayer if I showed you my upstairs office which you can look at if you want to
but I have a full like the office all set up in another room that room is full of books and
and a lot of stuff and people giving me you see all those stack of I just got an honorary doctor
degree from ethical college which you see there in the corner and that's the fourth one that I've
gotten and a lot of stuff was coming at me and I found myself not having children of my own I found
myself wondering what's going to happen to all of this stuff gathering not just here I walk up
stairs if you want to and so it was like an answer to a prayer because I we started having meetings
and looking at what would it be a part of the rationale for it is that there are all these museums
not all these but you know in Birmingham and even Selma as the Rosa Parsons in Memphis museum and
the museums around the place and one person on our team said we have nothing in the northeast
and so other people started coming to me we were just sitting around here in my living room and now
we meet in places a couple of places around town two places with mostly a meat envisioning what
it would be and actually there's some programs that they my colleagues and the group has grown now
it has grown to about the steering committee we're calling it
seven six or seven people who meet regularly at least once or twice a month and envisioning what it
could be we need something in the northeast and and I'm honored that they chose me and because
well it was after I got an award at the Memphis Museum which was quite an honor was like being at
the Oscars I had the presidential suite and the anyway it was just wonderful so it just it's
just an evolving entity that somebody else had this idea and I'm so grateful as I said because I
wondered what would happen to all this stuff not a nice good way to speak of it but you know all
the stuff all the photographs and and statutes and things around you could just look at a wall as
you walk up my stairs a plaques and what am I going to do with it I have one sister who probably
take it to a dumpster but I have this group of friends who are putting it together and what we're
all working on it and I'm about to finish my book manuscript and I will have more input and
you know if something happens that or if there's an idea that doesn't relate to my theory my
philosophy my spirit which is something I've tried to push the group towards I don't want you
to develop something in my name if it doesn't if we don't see a spirit of quality and I don't mean
anybody's religion I just mean the spirit of quality I think we don't have good definitions for
spirit but but I want because that was so much a part of the civil rights movement of certain
a certain spirit and and you know it emanated from you know Martin Luther King Jr. and
and and just even he saw Jenkins who wanted to help these people on the bus he wasn't a preacher
but there was a certain spirit about him a certain spirit about septum of Clark a certain spirit
I know I will years ago I got into meditation and and and and knew and I accept the fact that
there is a spiritual aspect to life and I and because it was so much a part of the movement that
a spiritual quality I want to make sure that my friends are not so on a head trip that they
leave out the spiritual quality if it's going to if it's in my name and I've had just these kinds
of conversations with them but we are they've done some training with teachers and looking at
you know we have a whole plan which we could share with you it's all on paper curvy could give
you that on the flash if you a curvy edmunds to send you our business are not not business plan but
I are you know and there's a lot of stuff on paper I wish you would ask curvy if you took down
his phone number if he would send it to you and so you get some more background but we are
we are developing it and the vision is that somewhere down the road that we would actually have a
building and there's a lot of stuff here that would you know this it's like it's somewhere for
it to go now and that they wanted to honor me and as well and and also create a place where we
would do have people do you'd probably be surprised at the number of people who have no way to tell
their story even people in the north who have had an experience who went south and participated in
them in a march but I certainly want people to know and I said this a lot that I
I want people to know that we did something other than march that's the reason
that I highlight the citizenship education program in the book that I've done just about finished
because it's on this note to finish the it's hard to imagine the movement taking the form that
it did without all of those persons who came to your chest and all of the persons they then went and
yes oh absolutely yeah those those are the people who made the movement in a real sense and
and I I have been troubled by the fact that three or four people
um all lifted up as the people who made the civil rights movement and even the fact that people
just talk about they say things like I marched with Dr. King and and and I say this when I do
lectures or speeches that uh we didn't just march it was a it was a whole just big operation
you know going on and I tell them of course about the citizenship workshops which was my
responsibility and and this uh I don't know if I even mentioned the fact that yeah and when
anda started to move away into uh the political life uh a number of people moved into other
aspects of working to make this uh and in other venues to make this a a better country uh I don't
know how much we said about what happened after Dr. King's death but people things well I you
know I went to be head start director but I came back and worked for me to jackson and uh but even
now people talk about um for example we all know I love John Lewis but people talk as though John
Lewis was the only one on the Edmund Pettus Bridge because he got this cacossa and then Mrs uh
uh oh her name went eluded me you probably in the in Alabama oh gosh shame on me
I'll tell your name in a minute she was knocked down by one of those horses on the on the uh the
the bridge and uh and and and and a lot of folk but it's like the one person gets lifted up as the
uh either the leader or the key person and uh I mean there are a lot of things I would like to
say but I'm not even sure I want to say them on tape but it's it's every time that uh you know
people talk as though Jesse Jackson and two or three other folk were the intimates of Dr. King
and they were not and uh and uh I shouldn't have said that on tape but I've said it now I can't
unsee it but but it's not to take anything away from them but some people are able to
I don't know capture a certain spot and the media looks for someone who would make it not just
not only controversial um but who would be more uh media where they might be one way of uh
of looking at it gosh I don't know what's going to happen uh
um Dr. King was um
boy he was really troubled almost kind of choking and this was the week
the week that he died we were there for a meeting that's why Jesse happened to have been there
the day Dr. King was killed so he's showing on the balcony and that gets interpreted as though
Jesse was you know just a real intimating but it flew down from Chicago for meetings you know once
in a while and uh and some and you know it was a worker a worker and it's on right but uh
uh I wish it could be on tape I don't want everybody to think I've made this up but for Dr. King to say
Jesse pushed me and he pushed him because uh you know he could have he was a tall
guy Dr. King was short fellow and but the fact that Jesse would push him
um to get and it was easy for Jesse to get um you know for first dibs on the cameras
but but till this day when when I hear people um talk as though three or four people made the
movement I find that really really troubling um and I'm not though when Dr. King said that too
maybe nobody else would uh you know would say it something else I was gonna tell you about that
but but that's um I'm really glad you all are doing this because it's not that I'm after you
know publicity but uh but it's just that I don't want the history to go down as though three or four
people made it when they didn't and and and weren't even on a daily basis there uh but we're doing
their own thing and some wanted their own thing and uh you know I need not call any names and they
wanted to uh pull whatever they could just to themselves but it's a distortion that that troubles me
well it's it's the reason one of the reason many reasons I'm so grateful for this interview and
also to know two that you are so far along in your manuscript and we can look forward to it.
So I'll spread out on my dining room table there a woman that comes over to help me uh we are doing
editing I got I sent the whole thing off to my publisher so I mean she used to but uh and she says
about little notes can you say a little more about this can say a little more about that so uh and the
woman who comes over she's more technically competent than I am and uh and and I can write and say
I do want to say this or input this and I just hand it over to her and she inputs it into
existing chapters and that's too tedious for me I don't know if I'd get it finished if I didn't
have that kind of help. Well I guess what I've just said in my final thoughts but I'll say it
another way or maybe it's um my my thought is I'm glad for the this opportunity to talk with you all
uh just to to hopefully bring forth the notion of uh the real story at a sentence not not because
seeing in wanted to to have a big media blitz but or or any or any uh you know the media because
they want what's what will sell you know if uh and so they pick two or three people um it's like
um well I think I yeah stop. What a great great pleasure and privilege to be with you thank you so much.
Well thank you. This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian
National Museum of African American History and Culture.